it starts with legalizing it regulating
it collecting data from that regulated
market and then circling back and
adjusting as the data warrants us to the
herd stoner enthusiasts doesn't want to
hear about how it's not awesome and the
folks that believe it's evil don't want
to hear that it's okay we put on the
world cannabis Congress people who were
there are only the the movers and
shakers in the industry probably own 400
million dollars in deals that happened
at the conference you're looking at 15
different pillars of corporate social
responsibility that would include things
like environmental stewardship
traceability accountability and and
protecting consumer what's up everyone
welcome to simulation I'm your host Don
sake on we are at the new West Summit
the world's leading cannabis tech
conference we have a special guest with
us we have Damon Goodwin thanks for
coming out of the show we appreciate you
coming on as the year of the VP of
Revenue and partnerships at civilized
civilized OTT life links in the bio
check it out
and how would you describe it cuz from
my first glance I was like this is
really beautifully designed it's giving
me really prominent cannabis related
news information so yeah give us a
little bit about yeah thank you for that
really civilized as a lifestyle brand we
have a number of different properties
where we discuss cannabis in a different
way than the traditional approach
there's a lot of content out there
that's more of a STONER porn for lack of
a better word and can civilize is really
hopefully adding to the conversation in
a civilized manner so being that bridge
between mainstream and cannabis culture
to to really have an end goal of
normalizing cannabis discussion and use
making it really just another one of the
products we consume for those people who
enjoy travel and food and lifestyle and
who happen to enjoy cannabis but don't
define
selves by that use I feel like civilized
is the perfect way for your parents to
underlie this is actually a decent way
to portray cannabis you know if we carry
on that idea you think about the great
properties that cannabis has from an
anti inflammation standpoint and you
think about the seniors who could
probably benefit from a cream CBD cream
on their knee but they're afraid well
it's you know it's cannabis so I've been
taught over the last hundred years to
avoid that because it's evil rather than
you know what let's talk about the
benefits let's talk about the research
that exists understanding that there's
probably more research that needs to
happen it's it probably is not good for
everything probably doesn't cure the
common cold but kids with seizures I
don't think anybody's arguing that
that's a bad thing that cannabis can
help those kids so with your with
regards to your parents if they could go
somewhere and find out a little bit more
about it and it was a trusted content
and kind of fun they would go and learn
that maybe I should give it a go and I
should do it in this way in this very
responsible manner I'm gonna dabble in
cannabis and find out more civilize
could be one of the ways whether it's
through our events or through our
content one of the ways that they could
learn about it and and potentially use
it responsibly I think you're
popularizing cannabis news and culture
in ways that are a little bit like you
said it's kind of like an a knotch in a
different direction than kind of a lot
of the stoner culture and a more of a
kind of like a professionally like
design sort of like a news desk
direction and I like the different
disciplines that you guys were proposing
as well you were talking about how there
are certain like Air Canada's not
enabling their employees to use cannabis
when they're off the clock and like you
know you were really you know poking out
really important these are you're
basically poking out what is pressing
for us to discuss around cannabis
conversation and a real one knowing that
on one side you know it's it's very
polarized right so the side that won't
listen it's actually both right the
stoner the hard stoner enthusiast
doesn't want
here about how it's not awesome and the
folks that believe it's evil don't want
to hear that it's okay so if we could
actually just take a minute
calm down have a civilized conversation
a real conversation about facts we'll
find that it's probably somewhere in the
middle and then if you use cannabis
responsibly it's certainly not evil in
any way recreationally you should be
able to have fun with it if used
appropriately and medicinally there's
probably value in to cannabis and a
number of conditions that we don't even
know enough about yet because you can't
do the research because it's evil so as
time marches on in places like Canada
have open it up October 17th a big day
where we have federal legalization as
well as provincial legalization so we
have medicinal we have recreational up
in Canada the United States you know
with the federal limitations it's still
very difficult to do any kind of
research so there's some great
initiatives happening right across
Canada in partnership with government in
partnership with private money putting
that together to really find out about
cannabis both how it works chemically
you know you know what strains do and
and how that works as well as the
socio-economic impact and that and
that's something that you know civilized
talks about and and again at the same
time it's something that we convene
meetings around so we we put on the
world cannabis Congress which is a
premier event invitation-only modeled
after the World Economic Forum so like
Davos it's hard to get to it's expensive
to go but the people who were there are
only the the movers and shakers in the
industry from a government perspective
we have 14 countries there last year and
again politicians the deputy prime
minister was there which would be the
same thing as having the Vice President
of the United States there to attend a
cannabis Congress so you think it from
which country so this was that was the
Deputy Prime Minister of Canada as well
as the premier of the province so be
like having the governor of the you know
the state
you know of New Jersey and the
vice-president going to a cannabis
congress to talk about the benefits of
Responsible use our teen countries
that's great you guys throw this every
year the world cannabis Congress
upcoming its upcoming in June where is
it it's in st. John New Brunswick which
is in Atlantic Canada right on the water
it's a one-hour time zone east of New
York so yeah North go yeah if you're
from the United States you go up and
hanger right so yeah yeah and so if
people would like to go they can apply
to receive an application at the world
cannabis Congress website and and at the
same time it's a curated conversation
where most of the panelists are keynotes
and other con types of Congress and it's
not your typical folks it's the the
highest echelon and and all of the major
businesses are there in the cannabis
space globally so doing my next question
to you then would be what is discussed
amongst the people they're like what are
the most pressing subjects that people
are talking about yeah so I mean they
are broken down into three streams so
there's policy and obviously the
government folks are very you know
interested in finding out more about
that there's business and not just how
to grow your business or acquisition
there's a lot of talk about ancillary
companies much like the Gold Rush it
wasn't the miners who made money it was
the people who sold the the shovels and
the pickaxes right and then innovation
and talking about new delivery systems
the technology the data around data
collection so all of the new innovations
that are happening in the space and and
you get a lot of interesting
conversations and all of those but
policy probably the best example of that
and what many companies are grappling
with are is medicinal
like medicinal use at the workplace and
so if you look at the challenges around
that if I have a prescription for
medicinal use cannabis and I'm going to
work can I get in trouble for that as a
company and someone you know drives over
somebody with a forklift and they were
on
100 milligrams of THC what does that
mean and so I think you know we had
folks from leading human resource
professionals from around the world come
and participate in that conversation and
it got very interesting and mostly
around the the fit to work definition
whereas which essentially stipulates as
long as you're not doing anything poorly
on the job then you're fit for work and
if you happen to have a pint of beer as
in the UK which which allows employees
to have a beer at lunch as long as
you're fit for work in the afternoon
then you're fine I think a lot of groups
will head towards that but in an
incredibly litigious society like the
United States that's going to be a
little more complicated and so there's a
whole bunch of things that need to be
figured out and who do you figure out
you know so we convene a meeting of all
of the the leaders thought leaders in
the various areas of policy business and
innovation with great government support
so federal government kicks in money and
preventional government kicks in money
and then industry kicks in large amounts
of money so that we can put on you know
a world-class event networking amongst
the upper echelon as well as not so much
informing what's happening but shaping
it yeah yeah so yes this career that's a
great example on policy and again we're
talking about you know shaping what the
future is gonna be like that's really
important with other important thought
leaders I also think you know
disseminating examples like what you
just taught us here if we can continue
doing that for the public they can
become more informative more involved in
shaping some of the decisions for
example we're not really thinking about
like you just gave us the policy at the
workplace maybe you teach us about you
were saying also business and data where
the other ones give us a little bit of
how your shape and business yeah so so
when it comes to business we find out
about you know what the movers and
shakers what what exactly is driving
them what's keeping them up at night and
then also allowing them the opportunity
to make deals and acquisitions and that
type of thing so business gets very
interesting we we tracked a number of
deals probably one 400
million dollars in deals that happened
at the conference so we we arranged at
the request of sponsor to be connected
with certain individuals that they did
not have relationships with we put them
on a boat a cruise you know through the
beautiful kind of encases river and by
the time they get off that boat a deal
was struck and it was a substantial deal
so so we we you know helped business do
business and a big part of doing
business is regulatory regulation we had
Health Canada their department justice
ministers and policy you know from the
elected side as well as you know senior
bureaucrats so that there were pressing
issues that you could address over you
know some fresh lobster out of right out
of the ocean and and and it's funny how
you can get past boundaries and and
preconceived ideas of somebody when
you're having fun in a beautiful
location but with a purpose to to get
something done so so business very very
happy there and I would say the number
of deals and the size of those deals
that occurred is probably the best
example of how business benefited from
the world cannabis Congress and then
thirdly in terms of innovation it's a
two twofold one is you know others
learning about the various technologies
that exist one one such technology by a
very smart company out of eastern Canada
just a small company but they've got
dispensed and like a like you know like
you'd go to a cigarette machine or or to
a coca-cola machine or a vending machine
and and be able to get your cannabis
Redbox was a big one does that to
dispense you Inc like there's a number
of them now and they're doing it in
different ways a dispenser for example
is working with inner-city youth in who
have addiction issues in helping
researchers do research directly on the
opiate crisis in in some very troubled
neighborhoods and so using the Vedant
vending machine with a bio sign in sign
off so you could really control who was
getting it how they were getting
and also be able to track that and so if
you're dispensing methadone to help
someone get off of oxycontin and you'd
have that opportunity as a researcher
just to ensure that you know they're
dealing what they're supposed to be
doing and ensuring that compliance which
is so important when you're doing
research project right so so
technologies like that where other
people get to go holy smokes like okay
though I didn't know about that
technology some other people
particularly those who are tasked with
dealing with the opiate crisis have oh I
didn't know about that option now I can
take a look at that
at this year's Congress we've got a
research day where we're bringing
researchers from around the world to
specifically shape the future of
research on the first day of the
Congress and then the next two days of
the Congress will happen as it has
previously so we're gonna add in
addition to get policy business and
innovation now research will will take a
foremost place and it will be not just
medicinal scientific chemical research
but also that socio-economic peace
understanding the policy implications of
legalization and cannabis use in various
segments of population so yeah I love
the research day that comes before and I
love all the examples that you were
giving there think there are again just
really relatable the future is kind of
that on demand sort of deliveries of
everything that we'd like and and uh how
do you ensure someone that's tapering
away from a addictive like
pharmaceutical that's transitioning over
to a cannabis is actually taking
hopefully less addictive exact and
hopefully we know so little about the
actual personalized effects of different
strains and different drugs on ourselves
so there's so many biomarkers to analyze
and understand you also mentioned data
what is going on with data in the
industry so you know a lot is happening
in data and and no matter how much that
is happening it's probably still not
quite enough I mean you you look at what
folks like Canales asur new frontier
data are doing in terms of data
collection
data collection understanding trends we
do research with a company called PSB
research out of Washington DC we do an
annual poll I think it's going into its
fourth year where we try to understand
the thoughts and feelings around
cannabis really it's weird when you're
inside the industry you think that
everybody loves cannabis but while
there's a legal license to to sell
cannabis more and more that social
license does not yet exist in fact the
vast majority of folks are okay with
legalization because it's going to get
money out of organized crime and it'll
keep kids maybe hopefully further away
from getting access to cannabis that's
the hope it's not because they
essentially think that cannabis is great
there acquiescing they're saying that
you know what the current war on drugs
is probably not working we need a new
strategy and and that strategy will be
legalization regulation taxation and
flowing it through but it's not that
they love cannabis if we could make a
baby step to say cannabis is good used
appropriately cannabis is good if we can
get there I think I think that hasn't
happened yet and and I think it's very
easy to get the enthusiasts and the
industry to absolutely agree to that but
the naysayers how do you get them on
board and yet at the same time you look
at companies like acreage and they
brought on you know John Bainer very
interesting who was someone it was in a
position to to look at the social
justice or injustice of cannabis and and
wasn't did not choose to do anything at
that time in a positive direction who is
now profiting from from cannabis and and
I think there's a little bit of a you
know we have to you know ask ourselves
questions as to why that is and at the
same time say that you know it's okay to
change your mind because we need society
to change this mind as it relates to
cannabis and not to say that it is the
best thing ever and cures a common cold
but if used appropriately probably okay
and may be good and I think we got there
I think that'd be awesome yeah I like
how you're you're taking it from person
of this sort of communal sense making
that if we can take that first step what
is 101 101 is cannabis has good
properties if used appropriately so
let's agree on that and then find out
what those good properties are as we do
that for the right patient or the right
time all that kind of stuff right on so
that's how you know I like that as kind
of a moving moving the ball forward okay
so we are at in new s summit we are at
here with just leaders and innovators in
the industry there's so many different
ways that disciplines that are getting
involved in this space yeah the
blockchain AI a or VR you know there's
just endless amounts of technologies
they're getting involved in the space
yes so what do you find most interesting
out of all of the technologies that are
getting involved in the space yeah for
me it I have 25 plus years coming from
Pharma of being involved with some
pretty snazzy research over time I think
technologies that help us change the
conversation from one of anecdotes and
feelings to one that is based on
evidence and facts I think that that
change will actually dramatically change
the conversation
I think it'll overnight reduce stigma I
think when people will see and again I
look back at Sanjay Gupta's CNN
documentary series you did like a
two-part series on cannabis it was the
first time that mainstream really saw
the benefits for people with seizures
and kids with seizures and you can draw
a line from that that documentary
directly to epidural X getting covered
as an fda-approved medication for
children right so I I think evidence so
when I when I you talk about technology
for me it's about you know the delivery
system so how can we you know I would
probably I'd be willing to say that from
a societal standpoint smoking of in any
kind is probably frowned upon I think
that's probably fairly safe to say if
you're a physician you're quite likely
or unlikely to say you know what smoke
as a delivery system vape edible oil
maybe okay pill form with a very
specific tight dose probably okay
medicinally so the delivery methods are
very interesting we know that the lungs
are probably the best way to bring it in
or one of the best ways to bring it in
and then you look at all of the
different devices from RESPA mat to the
puffers and all of the different ways of
getting you know asthma medication and
COPD medication into your body could you
use that for cannabis while there's lots
of companies working on different
delivery system technology so that's
kind of interesting when we talk about
data data collection house collected all
that kind of stuff where you've had in
the United States you still have federal
illegality as it relates to cannabis
[Music]
collecting data is complicated and
difficult people also don't want to give
information around it and particularly
their use and so there's a lot we don't
know right in in Canada hopefully things
are changing a little bit people be more
open about about their cannabis use we
feel and civilized and we actually hope
to be a place where people can come who
are in in the closet who are the
cannabis closet and can they can come
and find out more and see that it's okay
it's okay if you're using it we look at
our demographics for our 3 million
unique visitors monthly to our civilized
life property and you can see that it's
affluent people 50/50 split men and
women they're married they exercise a
lot there so they're generally speaking
healthy members of society were very
productive and the kind of people that
that we aspire to be and they're
cannabis users and so I think that those
technologies again that that help people
understand it have that help cannabis be
more effective medicinally
recreationally that encourage
appropriate use those kinds of
technologies will be the winners
I like I like that vision yeah the yeah
yeah that vision seems like where we
want to go healthy productive people
that are also choosing to you know do
what they want you know a little bit of
cannabis a little bit you know do
whatever you'd like as well and in again
in ways that are you know benevolent for
themselves benevolent for society yeah
okay so I think that that's pretty good
any last thoughts for wrapping up one
thing I would like to talk about is a
global initiative that happened that's
been going on for about a year now and
it's called the global cannabis
partnership and I think that's something
that that folks should be aware of it's
a it's a very robust initiative around
corporate social responsibility that has
recently gotten going 26 companies are
members of the global cannabis
partnership and it seeks to in the same
way that Lottery did and probably did
probably the best it has government
private companies and supporting
companies that like like accounting
firms and lawyers that all coming
together to create a framework around
corporate social responsibility certain
standards and and then whether it's
aspirational or because you are doing it
really great you'd become a member of
that organization and be judged and
measured by the various standards that
are set so currently I think they're
looking at 15 different pillars of
corporate social responsibility that
would include things like environmental
stewardship traceability accountability
and and protecting the consumer it's
kind of neat it's a one at Rick Peterson
who's one of the consultants wanted kind
of a legend in the corporate social
responsibility space who has been
helping to create this group Rick says
you know what if you're going to be
transparent out there
you better be buff so so hopefully that
this is a way of companies governments
ensuring that they're doing everything
right as an industry we have this
opportunity at a very young industry to
avoid the pitfalls that lottery had with
video lottery gaming and addictive
gambling and all of the there was a lot
of bad things that happened and then
they they brought they really were the
the fur
group to create this kind of framework
that was then copied by tobacco and
alcohol members of the global cannabis
partnership include a why PwC who will
be holding these companies accountable
and ensuring that they they're doing
what they say they're doing we have a
lot law firm McCarthy tetro that's a you
know from a regulatory standpoint
ensuring everything is top drawer and
then constellation brains canopy growth
were áfreeá
all of the big licensed producers
vertically integrated companies are
members of this organization and I think
going forward again to ensure we do get
that social license and to ensure we as
an industry behave having that kind of a
partnership which includes government so
it's sort kind of shortcuts having it's
not a lobby group and it's not an
advocacy group rather it's more of all
of us being together to say let's behave
appropriately and if we do so we will
accelerate that the the finding out
what's appropriate and behaving in an
appropriate manner and reducing stigma
and normalizing cannabis use the global
cannabis partnership is that say having
not only the congregation of the
different leadership and governments and
corporations but then also what is the
action whatever like the action items
would they give you know 5 or 10 percent
of the of the profit for for doing
something in low SES areas or you
explain
yeah it'll include initiatives like that
that the group wants to do kind of as a
group I think probably the best example
comes from the lottery so the world
lottery Association corporate social
responsibility framework that that the
GCP is modeled after they noticed that
problem gambling starts when you're
young and that if you were gambling as a
kid you're way more likely to be a
gambler a problem gambler later on so
they did some research to discover that
then when they found that out they said
okay what do we do to fix that as an
industry and they started education
programs like you know don't put scratch
and win ticket in your kids stocking
Chris
let's educate the public on how they can
avoid becoming a problem gambler that's
the kind of action that would need to
happen so again with cannabis as it
relates to be taught and taking stock
understanding you know don't put an
eighth in the cannabis further that's
right yeah
definitely well I it's a good point what
age should you start right so so so and
for what condition and and
recreationally how soon are their
impacts on the mind there's there's
evidence to suggest under 24 probably a
bad idea right well there is research to
suggest that again it's about the
quality of research and understanding
you know how you know what we should be
recommending and then once you have that
information as an industry we say you
know what this research revealed this
truth and and if we can't dispute the
truth and whatever that revealed then we
have to row in that direction to make
sure that we're you know addressing that
head-on rather than you know trying to
do some kind of marketing or PR move to
how to sweep it under the rug right like
get the neuroscientists in and because
cause daddy cognition Peaks around that
age too so that's not that that might be
associated with that okay just I guess
then just to play on that just for
another just quick moment on the way out
because I want to know then how do you
feel about youth and young adults
getting involved in in cannabis how do
we appropriately open up the possibility
for them to to use cannabis for creative
purposes or for whatever they want
without the you know with decreasing the
likelihood to as close to zero as
possible for the them to get addicted or
yeah yeah so again I think there's a
lack of research I think so it sort of
starts with more research needed on that
in in really socio-economic research or
even post hoc research survey research
about people who have used it and how
that's affected them I mean we generally
speaking inside the industry see
cannabis is a non-addictive problem
property right that being said speaking
with experts experts psychiatrists in
addiction they would disagree they say
they know 10% or at least are becoming
addicted to cannabis user so I think be
honest like that yeah and have a real
conversation and then say okay how do we
go about it right if it was a super low
THC high CBD product is there benefit
there does that help
are there ways that we can limit it and
I think it starts with legalizing it
regulating it collecting data from that
regulated market and then circling back
and adjusting as the data warrants us to
do taxing the group have a leak so that
those tax dollars can be spent to help
those people or either education and/or
if we do make a boo-boo and people are
hurt how do we we should be able to fix
that so yeah it that's one of the
trickiest things I think about the
industry is we don't do it if we don't
do it and we and we just kind of go
along hoping for the best Kenny Kenny
Kenny like if it doesn't go I think
we'll have a few more boo-boos yeah not
so good so good I love it this has been
a fantastic conversation nuanced and
multidisciplinary about the cannabis
industry I really like that a lot I
really appreciate it thanks for coming
on the show Haven really appreciate that
civilized odd life in the bio go check
them out also thanks for tuning in go
and build go create after you check out
this content go and manifest your
destiny into the world thanks for
checking it out everyone and much love
we'll see you soon
[Music]